- So, what we're going to do today
is actually put a plasmid into E. coli.
So E. coli is a type of bacteria,
it grows really quickly.
So that's why we use it in lab.
And we want to make sure
that the only bacteria we're playing with
are the ones we've picked.
So that's why we wear gloves.
So we don't get any of our
bacteria in our experiments.
And what I have is basically ethanol,
like hand sanitizer, but
just the alcohol part.
And I wipe my hands and my bench first.
Pretty standard now that it's 2020,
and gestures broadly.
But we keep our benches clean with this.
And I just keep the paper towel with me.
And I'm trying not to touch
my laptop with my glove,
but I'll probably mess up and
you can yell at me for that.
Let me just adjust the camera
so you can actually see the bench.
(indistinct) glove box.
Okay, I will hold up things to y'all.
Maybe I can sit (indistinct).
Let me make this shorter.
Perfect, okay, yeah.
So now that we've cleaned the bench,
the next thing is we want to
make sure the air gets clean.
So the way we do that
is we put on a flame,
like fidget a little candle or lighter
to kind of force the air to move,
so that all of the dust
and stuff isn't in the way.
It's kind of hard to see the blue flame,
but super cool small fire.
And what we're going to
do is put DNA into cells.
The DNA we're using has the
gene for antibiotic resistance.
Basically, they'll be able to survive
on this drug called Kan or Kanamycin.
And we do that so that
we can kind of either see
how that gene does things,
or we can use it as a
marker for another gene
we're interested in.
So the next question I'm going to ask is
why do we want to clone things?
Y'all are all geneticists now.
So why do you think you'd
want to clone anything?
Give you like 10, 15 seconds.
Awesome, I'm gonna close this one,
because everyone voted,
and y'all are so smart.
You're totally correct.
All of the above.
So some of the reasons we do study genes
or why we clone things is
to investigate the functions of new genes.
We have this chunk of DNA, and
we don't know what it does.
It gets really confusing
when it's in like it's natural,
either like mouse or a human.
So we put it in something
really fast, E. coli.
Study mutations,
some of y'all specifically
enjoy this idea.
Yeah, so we can't always put
a mutant gene into a mouse,
because we don't know
what it's going to do.
Or we want to have more
like specific understanding.
So we'll make that
mutation, put it in bacteria
and see if they can grow,
exploring interactions of groups of genes.
Totally, if I take away one
gene, does this still work?
Do the bacteria turn from
like a gross yellow color
to something cool, like green or a blue?
And there are tons of other reasons,
but those are the first ones.
Fantastic, so how do we do that?
Well, now that everything's all set up,
I have a tube here of cells.
I apologize.
My handwriting's not that good.
And we keep it on ice
because they like to be cold.
And then, I have two tubes where I'm going
to put my transformations in.
I feel like a beauty YouTuber,
and this is the product.
And then I have this little tiny tube,
like super tiny, that says plasmid.
Oh man, you really can't read that at all.
And it's my DNA.
It's like this teeny tiny amount.
So I can't remember
if I set this poll correctly or not.
Let's double check.
Yes.
So we know that we're trying
to put this antibiotic
resistance gene into the cells.
So what we want to see is
that when we have this gene,
the cells can survive an antibiotic.
And when we don't have this gene,
the cells can't survive in an antibiotic.
So what do you think is
the best negative control
for this experiment?
Just raise your hand
if you're not familiar with
what a negative control is.
If you're not what, we can
go over it super quick.
Okay, so we got a couple not sure.
Is anyone sure of what
a negative control is?
If you are feel free to chime
in chat, or unmute yourself,
whatever you're comfortable with.
It's cool.
It's early.
If you don't want to chime in, no problem
but I will give you this one.
A negative control is something
where we know what the outcome will be.
If we control it, we know what it'll be.
And negative means we know
something won't happen.
So if you wanted to test if
coffee helps keep you awake,
you expect coffee to keep you awake.
So a negative control
is something you expect
not to keep people awake, like
maybe water or chamomile tea.
So we're just waiting for
a couple of more people.
No biggie.
If you're not super confident in this one,
it's good so far.
Just two more people,
feel free to click on any answer,
and then I'll close the poll.
Last person, you got five seconds.
That's okay.
The internet is hard, and
it's also pretty early.
I'm just gonna end the poll where it is.
So overall, y'all got
this perfectly right.
Great job.
I also want to congratulate everyone
who picked either of
the first two options.
The first answer,
transforming a plasmid we know works
and has our resistance
gene, is a positive control.
It's a control.
We know what the answer will be.
And we know something will happen.
We know they will grow.
Back to that coffee example,
it's like giving someone a caffeine pill.
You know that caffeine
will keep them awake.
Plating water only is
also a negative control,
but it's not the best one.
The best is transforming
cells with no plasmin.
That way we can make sure
when we're heating them up
and giving them this like
really good recovery media,
basically, like Coca-Cola for cells,
something they really
like to drink or grow in,
we know we're not like
somehow making them resistant
just by how we're manipulating them.
And I always like to
use a negative control.
It's like the best science practices,
but you'll run into
people who don't use them,
because they're more confident.
But not great, you should try to do that.
So now that we're done with that,
we'll actually do some of pipetting,
the most fun part of science.
I'm just gonna re-clean my gloves.
Take out two tubes.
I'll do everything pipetting in the air
so you can see.
We're going to take a really small amount.
So it's going to be, I'm
just using a micro-pipette,
and just turning it down, like
using this to turn it to 4.5.
And this is 4.5 microliters.
So really, really small amount.
These are tips that go on the pipette.
I'll put one on,
kind of like a little
needle, but it's not sharp.
Just you can see,
you can (indistinct) with it.
But now this isn't clean.
So I inject it all.
Get a new one that is clean.
Take some of my cells, pop it open.
Take up my 4.5 microliters.
I'm going to just show you
how small of a volume that is.
Like it's only going up to here.
And if you...
Do it like that.
I don't think you can see
but it's like, it's a teeny tiny drop.
This is an empty tube.
Even with the bubbles,
it only fills up that very
bottom bit down there.
So since we said that that's going
to be our transformation cells
plus DNA and plasmid.
And our negative control
is going to be cells
without the plasmid.
So in that tube again,
we'll take 4.5 microliters.
I'll put it in the tube.
Now, even smaller volume.
We're going to do 0.5 microliters of DNA.
This one is super.
I already have a teeny tiny PCR tube.
Again, I don't know
if you can see this, but it's so small.
I can inject it.
And it's just like less than a tear drop
or a raindrop.
We put that into our cells.
Because our cells are really gentle,
the way we mix things
is flick it like that.
Nothing big.
So in the perfect science,
we'd let this sit on ice for a half hour.
But through the magic of television,
we're not going to do that.
And then what we do is
we heat up these tubes
in a water bath.
So let me take y'all on a little walk.
We come over here.
Ooh, walked into a garbage can.
We have a (indistinct).
That's good.
Nope, there we go.
Water bath.
Just some water.
We put these guys in.
Come on.
I can never be a blogger.
You let them sit in that
water for about a minute.
This is making the cells really hot
and making them open up their membrane
so that the DNA that's
stuck on the outside
gets pulled into the inside.
This is heat track.
There are other ways
to transform bacteria,
like you can send a little
current through them,
a little bit of electricity,
and that'll make holes in the membrane.
I'm going to call that a minute
for the magic of television.
Let me take the tubes back out.
Let me sprint back to our bench.
Put these guys, oops, back on ice.
The ice helps their...
The holes we just made flows back up.
So all the DNA stays inside.
And then we're going to add
our largest volume so far,
50 microliters.
I'm using a different pipette this time.
This one's green.
It's also my favorite.
Don't know why, I just like it.
And we add some basically, sugar water
just another tube.
We'll take 50 microliters,
add it to each of them.
Oh, I can take them out of the ice now.
It's like we gave them the
thing they really, really like.
And so they're happy.
So we want to keep them warm
and mixing, that kind of stuff.
Beautiful.
You have two tubes
with our transformation,
control, little, little volumes.
And now we'd let that sit
for an hour in a 37 degree
incubator, 37 Celsius.
I don't know what that is Fahrenheit.
If anyone knows, you
can put it in the chat
because I'm not good at math.
Yeah, but again, magic of television.
We're not going to wait.
Now you take a Petri dish that I've made.
These are, it's kind
of like jello, bouncy,
and there's antibiotics in these.
So if the cells aren't resistant,
if they don't have the
resistance gene on the plasmid,
they won't be able to grow on this.
But if they do have that gene,
they'll be able to grow mo problem.
So, pretend that we waited that hour.
We're gonna take that
liquid that we just made,
our mixture of cells
that have sucked up DNA,
and that really good sugar water,
suck it all back up in our pipette,
and then squirt it onto this plate.
Now, we want to move it around.
You can see there's like a little streak
where the cells are.
And so, very fancy, we have hockey stick.
It's called a cell spreader,
but it's a hockey stick.
It's clean, so it was
individually wrapped.
And then you just move
it all around the plate.
Oh, I realize you all can't see that.
Move it around the plate.
Usually I do this flat on the bench,
but for for you guys, I'll lift it.
And we make sure we spread it out
so that all the cells
get all the way around.
So we'll do that for our transformation,
our negative control.
We always want to label the plates.
So we get a little marker.
We'll write on it, TO, transformation 1.
And then we let this sit
in the incubator overnight.
But again, magic of television.
We're back, it's tomorrow.
And we have some results plate.
Now, thank you Odaelys or Jeanne.
I'm not sure who's on the RockEDU account.
That 37 degrees Celsius
is about 98 Fahrenheit.
So, thank you, Odaelys.
And yeah, we have a bunch of plates,
and I'm going to give y'all polls
to help me figure out
what is on each plate.
So, first thing we have
is cells that don't...
Sorry I almost gave away the answer.
We have plates that don't
have any antibiotics on them.
You'll see, I've written minus Kan.
And instead of like that...
Let me actually lift up my laptop.
That'll be easier.
One moment.
Sorry for the challenge.
Instead of that clean,
empty plate we had before,
I'll put one out for comparison.
We now have plates with cells on them.
Okay, this is not working.
So empty plate,
you can see straight through to my hand.
There's nothing in it.
I'll take the lid off, even.
There's nothing on it.
And then, on these, we have bacteria.
You can really see it over
my sweater or mask, I guess.
So each of those dots is a colony.
So that came from a single cell.
And then where it's like
this big circling trunk,
it's a whole lot of cells bunched up.
You see you have some different sizes,
smaller ones, bigger ones.
And here again, whole bunch
at the top, all gunky.
Some single colonies down there.
I'm a vegan.
So to me, these plates smell
a little bit like pizza,
because they have yeast in them,
but that's neither here nor there.
So I'm going to launch one more poll,
or actually I'm going to redo
this one a couple of times.
Could you tell me what is on,
like did this transformation
include a plasmid?
This is on a plate that
doesn't have any antibiotics.
So this is just what
bacteria love to grow on.
There's no pressure to
have antibiotics or not.
I'll give you all a little bit more time,
and put this down, 'cause my arm is tired.
Okay.
I'm gonna give you 10 more seconds.
Five,
four,
three,
two, just click on any answer.
It doesn't matter.
And okay.
I'll leave it open while I talk.
So feel free to put in the right answer
after we go over this.
So y'all are about 50/50
split on yes and no.
And that's because we can't tell
from this plate, you're totally right,
everyone who put that.
And you're right to
have been super confused
by this question, because you can't tell.
These are plates without antibiotics.
Bacteria just love to grow
on this type of jelly.
So since there's no pressure,
no need to have the
antibiotic resistance gene,
you can't tell which
of these have plasmid,
which of these have the gene
for antibiotic resistance.
Because again, there are no
antibiotics on the plate.
So, great work.
That one was super confusing.
So if I, yeah,
if I relaunch, it'll clear
the existing results.
Now, don't answer the poll yet.
I have to show the plates,
but I've got gotta get my gloves on,
so I don't get bacteria
all over everything.
Now I'm going to cover this
little green cape I have,
reminding me which one has what on it.
So you see on this plate,
they say, plus Kan,
so that's the antibiotics.
This one has nothing on it.
There's nothing growing.
So kind of hard to see,
trying to get it on my
sweater or something.
Yeah, Oh, that's a better angle.
Nothing growing.
This one, look at all that gunk.
Got some at the top,
where it's a whole bunch of them,
some of the bottom that are singles.
And I shouldn't have launched the poll.
I didn't tell you which plate to do.
So I'm just gonna end it and restart it,
and then hold up one of them,
and y'all will tell me
if there's a plasmid
in that transformation.
So, this one, where you
have a ton of cells.
Look at all that stuff.
This is a plate that has antibiotics
and a ton of cells on it.
Almost everyone's in.
We'll do 10 more seconds.
Five, four.
Okay, again, I'll leave
it open while we talk.
Y'all are so smart.
Yes, there is plasmid
in this transformation.
Yeah, the thing that allows
antibiotic resistance
had to be put in the cells.
We transformed it in.
Now they can live on antibiotics.
Super cool.
Super useful.
The one with nothing growing on it,
because the antibiotics killed
all of the sensitive cells.
So yeah.
So good.
And that's because some of the reason
we do the negative control,
we do the cells without any DNA.
We want to make sure
that the cells weren't
already resistant to the drug.
If we grew on both the antibiotic plates,
then we gotta be like, Oh man, is that,
did I breathe on that?
Is there something else in there?
Maybe I forgot to add antibiotics.
I have done that.
Annoying, but not the end of the world.
And so, I'm a grad student.
I am not an artist.
Please forgive me.
But some of the other cool things
that we can do with
bacteria, we can do science.
That's great.
Obviously, I think that's great.
I've been doing this a little bit.
We can also make art.
I'm not an artist.
Forgive me.
I took one of those clean
plates with nothing on it.
And I did some drawings.
We have a smiley face,
a heart that's supposed to be a flower,
definitely can't tell.
This is a tree.
I'm not an artist, but I did put grass.
We have the sun, the moon,
and I accidentally hit the plate
when I was trying to draw this one.
So there are super cool,
like actual artists
who make art with bacteria
of different colors.
So there are some that
are like purple or green,
and some of the genes you can
put into bacteria are like,
Oh I can turn the flame off now.
Sorry.
Some of the genes you can put
in are like different colors.
So they can be like fluorescent green,
or this like cherry color.
And people make these
like beautiful plates
with all different colors
and all different parts.
So you can look that up in your spare time
if you're looking for that science
and art collaboration that
we've all been waiting for.
And one of my friends in school actually
runs a competition for science arts.
And she had like, I don't know,
four or five different types of bacteria
that are just naturally different colors.
Yeah, so that's some of
our cloning techniques,
how we usually do all of this stuff.
And I wanted to leave some time
for like questions, either
about what we did today.
If there are any polls
that you're still not sure about,
any like things you've
learned about in class.
If you want to get into
like the ethics of genetics,
like cool, we can put
genes in different things.
Could we do that to people?
And then should we do that?
Totally happy to discuss
that with you guys.
Y'all know all about this,
or like, if you want to talk about college
I went to SUNY, Stony Brook
a super fan of the New York schools,
friends that went to CUNY's,
Hunter, Brooklyn college,
How I got into science.
My parents are not doctors or scientists.
My mom was an elementary school lunch aid.
And my dad does computers
for some like office supply company.
Yeah, feel free to unmute
yourself, put things in the chat.
Take your time.
I have all day.
Yeah, Jeanne put in the chat
that she went to SUNY Geneseo
and came out with only a
little bit of student loans.
I feel that.
I did get a scholarship for Stony Brook.
So super minimal loans.
Really happy about that.
- [Teacher] Don't be shy guys.
You have any questions?
I did mention to them a little bit.
We have a question from Kailey
about what it is to be a PhD
candidate and researcher.
So I'm sure they'd love to hear
a little bit about that too,
but Kailey's asking
what's your favorite part
about your job?
- Oh, cool.
So I really like it when you get
to the end of like a
really long experiment,
and you've been working on this
for like a couple of weeks,
and then you finally find out something.
And it's most exciting when
it's not what you expected.
So if I did have cells that grew
on that negative control plate,
and I'm 100% positive
that it's not like contamination,
maybe I have another
negative control somewhere.
And then I'm like,
are these already
resistant to antibiotics?
And more in like a broad sense.
I'm in a lab that studies a pathogen.
So like, it's super cool to know
that you're working on
something that affects,
like 1/3 of the world's population
is already infected with TB,
that to know that like the
things you're doing every day,
could eventually, like actually
help someone is super cool.
And I'm just nerdy.
So I think it's neat every
time I get to see bacteria.
Anyone else?
I'll give you all a couple seconds
before we go, like, what is it?
Where was the gene introduced
to the bacteria taken from?
Elidey, not sure if I'm
saying that right, but thanks.
That's an awesome question.
Yeah, where did we get this
antibiotic resistance gene?
This is something that I
think is super interesting.
So bacteria, when they all live together,
they're all kind of mixed.
And just like the way like
lions will eat gazelles,
some bacteria express molecules
that kill other bacteria.
But they have to be
safe from that molecule.
So they express their own resistance gene.
It's like, if someone's
like, I don't know,
shooting arrows at like...
You are just spraying arrows
out at everyone around you.
You want to make sure you
and your like population has armor.
So you express the arrow, the antibiotic,
and the resistance gene, the armor.
So we took this from another bacteria.
Where we got it,
we got that gene from a company.
We ordered it,
and they sent us a little
piece of DNA in a tube.
And then we put it into our plasmid
with some other like restriction enzymes,
to cut up DNA, and the glue
to put it back together,
a DNA ligase or gluing it together.
But yeah, bacteria communicate,
and they fight and they
like tell each other how
and where to grow.
So we can take a lot of things from them.
The green fluorescent
protein I talked about
with the art, comes from jellyfish.
So they found this jellyfish
that naturally lights up green,
and then scientists figured
out which part of the DNA
let them do that, took it.
Now we put it in like bacteria
or tumor cells in cell lines
or mice or something,
so that we can follow these
green light-up proteins
or whole cells.
- [Teacher] When did you know
that you wanted to pursue science?
Was it sometime in high school?
Was it during your undergraduate career?
- Yeah, awesome question.
So in high school, I knew
I really liked science.
I had an awesome living
environment teacher
who like told all of us
we could be scientists.
I'm like, Oh, that's super cool.
But like, people like me
don't become scientists.
We're just like normal people.
So I wanted to be like an
elementary school science teacher
because I like teaching,
but I still wanted to learn about science.
So I went to undergrad.
Stony Brook was super good
about like getting everyone
involved in research.
So they're like, if you
want to try it, join a lab,
see what happens.
So I did, I was like,
Oh, I'll probably just
keep doing teaching things,
but might as well see
what research is like.
And then like I did, I worked in a lab,
I got to play with cells
and do experiments.
I was like, okay, cool.
Now I want to do this.
I didn't realize like we
could be part of science.
I thought I could just
like, watch it happen.
So I've always loved science,
but I didn't realize I could do it
until I got to undergrad.
So yeah.
- [Teacher] Thank you.
- Of course, yeah.
There's a question in the chat
about how my tuberculosis
research is going.
It's slow.
TB, like the E. coli we
were working with before,
doubles its population every 30 minutes.
So it's really fast.
TB doubles every 24 hours.
So it's really slow,
but I'm looking at genes
that are super important
in drug-resistant tuberculosis.
So when these cells
naturally can't be killed
by antibiotics,
what in their DNA is
letting them survive still?
So like, do they grow really slowly
so that the antibiotics can't get in?
Do they have like a
really thick cell wall?
So that even if there is
like stress inside the cell,
nothing from outside gets in.
I still have a lot to do,
but I'm really enjoying it.
Super fun.
Yeah.
So someone has asked about advice
for those who want to be in my place.
So yeah if you want
to be a science researcher, any capacity,
definitely like the first
step is to do undergrad,
probably in a science.
If you have the opportunity at that school
to do undergraduate research,
I super recommend it,
both from like an
application standpoint, like,
Oh, grad schools love to
see undergrad research.
But also from like, it's super cool.
You get to try all these new things.
And people, like grad students like us
are super excited to
have students come in,
young scholars like yourselves
who want to learn things,
who want to try stuff out in the lab.
And then as far as like advice goes,
one, know that you belong here.
You're super smart.
You're coming this far.
We need you.
We need young, smart scientists like you,
and all of the like different ideas
and perspectives you bring
from your backgrounds.
We want that.
And that not only do you belong here,
but like just because
something goes wrong,
you don't need to,
like, you can't give up.
The biggest thing is like keeping going
even when you get negative results,
or nothing grows on your plates.
So, I'm gonna let y'all
in on a little secret.
I did transformations of genes
that I was interested in.
'Cause like I have to
do it for my research.
At the same time as I was
making these for y'all,
and some of them work really nicely.
Like I got those little
colonies, little dots.
Some of them didn't.
There is nothing growing on this plate,
and there shouldn't be
things growing on it.
So a lot of science is like,
Oh man, I gotta do that again.
Or what did I do wrong?
Did I forget to add something?
Or is this just like not working
because the science is
it's a negative result.
So yeah, you just got to keep going
and really think about what you're doing.
And also, I'm going to
give y'all my email address
at the end.
So if you want to chat
more about like grad school
or undergrad, or even
like high school things,
I'm happy to talk about
all this kind of stuff.
And I can do it for a really long time.
Someone asked about any other
cool science, art ideas.
So since I'm a microbiologist,
I'm super partial to all
of the different like micro
painting with bacteria things.
But there are a lot of
like small groups that...
So I mentioned that I'm vegan, right?
So there is a whole
company out in California,
of course it's California,
making vegan cheese by having
E. coli make the milk protein.
So they cloned that whey
gene from cow's milk
into E. coli, and they
produce it like that.
So you could have legit vegan cow's milk.
You don't have to worry
about like the gross vegan cheese problem
where like it doesn't melt, or
it doesn't taste like cheese.
It's fully vegan, cruelty-free cows milk.
Same with like in vitro meats.
Like, Oh, what if we can make
a hamburger in a Petri dish?
I would eat that.
I'm not vegan
because I don't like the
way hamburgers taste.
They're very good.
As far as art goes,
there are people who make
like bioluminescent plants.
So plants that grow different colors,
and they have all these cool,
like little miniature gardens
with different light-up leaves.
I'm not super familiar
with the other ones,
but I think if you like
Googled biology art,
or something like that, you
could find really cool things.
There's this international genetically
engineered machine competition, iGEM,
that has high schoolers and
undergrads and grad students
do projects, and there's a
whole set of like tracks,
for people who just want
to make art with biology.
So they have some, yeah.
Oh Jeanne, you wanted to say something?
- [Jeanne] Yeah.
I'll share that the American
Society for Microbiology
has an art competition every year.
And if anybody has ever done urban barcode
or now BioBus,
Christine Marazzi, if anybody knows her,
she wins it all the time.
She (indistinct) New York city skylines
in different fluorescent colors,
like on big giant dishes of agar.
It's really cool.
You should check it out.
And I think there's another
company called Gingko Bioworks.
It's a Massachusetts-based startup,
that basically genetically
engineers whatever they can.
Like if you go to like a candle store,
or someone you know is
like selling candles
and those candles smell like rose,
a lot of times that rose odor,
it's made through
genetically-engineered microbes.
They just pump it out,
and then these companies buy these odors
and pop it into their
lotions and their candles.
It's one of the ways that we
get that smelliness, I suppose,
of our common products.
- Thank you.
I totally didn't know that.
- [Jeanne] It's fun.
I love thinking about the applications
of genetic engineering.
I feel like you can
basically dream up anything
and then make anything.
It's so cool, you know.
- [Teacher] It's a really great point too,
that along those lines,
the point that you're making Miss Eckartt,
of exploring new cruelty-free ways
to develop not only food products,
but things that you're bringing up to,
like, other types of products
that we use, absolutely.
- Anything else?
- [Teacher] Well, I want
to just take an opportunity
to thank you Miss Eckartt.
We really appreciate it.
If everyone would just unmute
and quickly give her some
snaps of appreciation.
(indistinct).
And thank you geneticists for
your active participation.
I know that you all got a lot out of this,
and hopefully you've been inspired.
I know several of you are future
scientists and researchers,
and we look forward to hearing
about your wonderful pathways
and discoveries in the future.
I want to thank Dr. Welwyn Pollard
who helped make this possible.
And Dr. Garbarino, who is a director
of RockEDU science outreach.
It's wonderful to see you again.
And it's been awhile since
we've been in the lab.
But it's lovely to see you again.
And thank you so much
for continuing to allow UHS
students to learn from you all.
We really appreciate you all.
- [Jeanne] My pleasure.
And we love having your students with us.
We love having you with us.
- [Teacher] Thank you, thank you.
- [Jeanne] (indistinct) your students.
- And thank you for letting
me share this with you.
Y'all are awesome.
You're super smart.
Yeah, do you have my email?
Or should I pop it in the chat?
What's best for everybody?
- [Odaelys] You can pop it in the chat,
and then I'll also send.
- Awesome.
- [Teacher] And I'll post it
on their classroom page, too.
- Fantastic.
- [Jeanne] We hope that
you'll keep in touch with us.
We have a lot of things going.
And one thing I want to plug is,
I don't know if you're familiar
with the Lab Jumpstart program.
But we would love for any student here
who might be interested like
building research skills
and then doing research during the summer.
So you would build research
skills in the spring,
and then in like an afterschool session.
And then you would build your...
You would like apply this to actually...
We would mail you a bunch of stuff,
and you could do potential
like microbiology experiments,
or even coding style of experiments,
in the summer under
mentorship of scientists
in a program called Lab Jumpstart.
And you also get a stipend,
so that you don't have to choose
between like if working during
the summer is your stick.
I know I always worked during the summer.
I would ask my parents
if I could like go to...
like Columbia had a microbiology program
for high school students.
And I really wanted to go to that.
And my parents were like,
no, you have to work.
And the Columbia program had
tuition associated with it.
And my parents were like, no way.
So we don't want to ever
put any kid in that position
where you want to do a program like this,
but you need to also work.
Maybe that's me like pushing
my own experiences on people.
But so yeah, we offer a really
nice generous stipend for it.
So I definitely encourage you to do that.
And somebody just said,
they like my guitar.
It's not, I wish I was that cool.
I do this on purpose.
But it's my husband's so,
but I look cool, right?
- [Teacher] You are cool.
- [Jeanne] Thank you.
- [Teacher] We certainly have
some really strong candidates
in this class.
They all received an email from me
when you all put it out to us,
but I'll make sure to promote that again.
Because I think for many students,
it's just an issue of like self-confidence
and like, you know would
I be able to do this?
And, absolutely. Absolutely.
You can.
- I feel you so hard.
I understand where you're coming from.
You know, I do not come from...
My mom is a high school dropout.
I'm a product of a teenage pregnancy,
and my dad did not go to college ever.
They didn't understand when I was like,
I got a 4.0 one semester.
And there was just like
that seems like a low number.
So it's I had to do,
I had to navigate this
whole place by myself.
And that's exactly why
we built the programs
that we built.
It's for you to not have to go
through that BS that I had to go through
of like sinking or swimming.
Like, that's not okay.
People should be supporting each other.
And these programs are
designed specifically
to make sure that even
if you feel not confident about yourself,
and none of us feel
confident about ourselves,
like 100% of the time,
so that's totally normal.
But like, we want to build you up.
I believe in building people,
who then build good science,
but if you don't have good people,
then you're going to have crappy science.
So I believe in people,
and I believe in science.
And together that's
what the Lab Jumpstart program represents.
So I hope you'll consider it.
We love our students.
We keep in touch with our students...
And exactly.
Oda wrote,
we want you to be
successful in whatever path,
and just have an appreciation for science.
You don't have to like be a scientist.
We just know how it works.
I mean how amazing is it
to have scientific literacy
in an age that we're in right now,
when we're going through.
Moderna just came out with like a vaccine,
efficacy studies.
Pfizer came out with
vaccine efficacy studies.
You want to be able to navigate
this type of information.
That's so impactful for our lives.
That's our goal.
We just want you to be
cool with that stuff.
You can go and do whatever you want.
- [Odaelys] (indistinct)
interest in science.
So we're looking for students who,
after this presentation or
some class that you've taken,
you became super interested in
finding out a little bit more
or wanting to do something more hands-on
in terms of getting to know...
Y'all are getting a feel
for what science is really like.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'll put out that
information to them again.
And I have to let them go
in a couple of minutes.
They have a fourth period class,
but we really appreciate you all.
And we love y'all.
We love science,
and we wish you all a wonderful
rest of the fall and winter.
We'll stay in touch for sure.
- Thanks everyone.
- Have a great day.
- [Teacher] Thank you, Miss Eckartt.